Steve Bannon is an outsider he claims to
have started a platform for the
extremist fringe all right movement he
also happens to be the White House chief
strategist with a direct line to the
most powerful man in the world Donald
Trump and he's had to reinvent himself
multiple times over his life and career
to get there this is the long weird
winding road of Steve bannon's ascent to
power let's start with bannon's younger
years he was born in 1953 to a
working-class irish-catholic family in
Virginia he then got his bachelor's
degree from Virginia Tech in 1976 he
moved on to get his master's from
Georgetown in 1983 and then his MBA from
Harvard in 1985 he also served in the US
Navy for seven years after the Navy he
landed at Goldman Sachs as an investment
banker and after a stint at Goldman
Bannen reinvented himself as a movie
producer executive producing a number of
politically charged documentaries that's
Joshua Greene Greene spent time with
Benin on and off for eight months for a
Bloomberg Businessweek cover story okay
getting back to Bannon a large chunk of
his financial success came from
requiring a piece in a fledgling TV show
by the name of Seinfeld which he still
receives royalty checks from to this day
but banner wasn't done reinventing vanna
took over as executive chairman for the
hard right populist publication
Breitbart after the death of its founder
that you know gleefully skewered
Republicans and Democrats alike
everything that we see in every trend
that we see is very strong to a
brilliant outsider's voice and an
outsider's movement to really take their
country back after Bennett took over
traffic for Breitbart exploded to record
levels
then came the 2016 presidential campaign
bringing drugs they're bringing crime
while Trump's politics were heavily
influenced by Breitbart Bannon also
turned the website into a Donald Trump
machine posting article after article
praising the Republican candidate in
August Bannon already successfully
mobilized the populist nationalistic
outright movement on the web to boost
Trump at the same time Donald Trump's
campaign was on the rocks so Trump
tapped Bannon to serve as his campaign
CEO and then this happened Donald Trump
wins Wisconsin surpassing the 270
electoral votes he would need to take
the presidency and Bannon was thrust
into the spotlight and with it harsh
criticism he was condemned by the ADL
the n-double-a-cp
and a number of Democrats and
Republicans who have called him
offensive
sexist and anti-semitic citing a number
of articles on Breitbart as well as this
the women that would leave this country
would be children you know there
wouldn't be a bunch of dice that came
from a number of petitions have sprouted
to keep Bannon out of the White House
but the White House chief strategist
does not mean sent a confirmation which
means Bannon is here to stay so how will
he wield his newly found power
his role in a Trump White House as being
keeper of the flame
I think panin is gonna be the guy as he
does own role in keeping Tripp honest
and keeping him aligned with a popular
idea that got elected first player so
from a Navy officer to a banker to a
Hollywood producer to a nationalist
mouthpiece to the White House Steve
Bennett has one last thing that he will
try to reinvent America
[Music]